commemorations in Moscow to mark the
73rd anniversary of the Soviet Union's
entry into World War two but the current
conflict in Ukraine overshadowed the
ceremonies President Putin welcomed the
ceasefire calling it an important first
step but he said Ukraine wasn't honoring
it so Genoa unfortunately military
action is continuing and last night
there was an artillery attack from the
Ukrainian side I cannot say who is
responsible the army or armed militias
all military action must stop these
people have no faith in the ceasefire
refugees from eastern Ukraine who have
just arrived in Russia the government
has erected a refugee camp near the town
of Rostov for the increasing numbers of
people seeking shelter ukrainian
President Petro poroshenko has offered
to engage in talks with moderate rebels
under certain conditions eliz intial
mughal if i'm offering a peace plan our
goal is to restore Ukraine's territorial
integrity by any and all means necessary
but peace is the priority we work you
but few believed peace will come soon
pro-russian rebels who control the Nets
refused to recognize the ceasefire they
vow to defend the city against the
Ukrainian army at all costs